let me get your reaction to one more
thing there's a big controversy
regarding a film
that seems to be over sexualizing
children and again it goes back to our
topic
talking about targeting muslim youth
because
you have an actual family that has a
daughter in there that's
wearing you know you know when we wear
this uh the woman wear the hijab they're
actually
imitating mary the mother of jesus i
don't know if you knew that
uh you know it's oh i haven't seen it
but i did read a
summary about it yeah so so that that's
that's why she's wearing the hijab
that's why any woman
uh a muslim woman they wear the hijab
because of our deep love for jesus peace
be upon him and his blessed mother
mary call her maryam so we're trying to
imitate her
in modesty now i'm gonna go ahead and
share this
have you heard of this film called
cuties
yes it's called cuties yeah and it's
young girls before they're not they're
not even teenagers yet
and they are going against their parents
because they wanted to join a dance team
where it's a very sexualized dancing
called twerking
so so how does this fit in with what
we're talking about
what the way it fits in is when i read
through the international planned
parenthood
they talk a lot about sexual rights and
that
they talk a lot about sexual pleasure
and that sexual pleasure
is the right and it is the right of
actually
in the sex education standards i was
shocked when i read it
um it said that it is the fundamental
sexual consent is the fundamental right
of people of
all ages so
they're really stressing um kids having
sexual rights
i mean this this seems like more uh a
a growing push also for pedophilia
absolutely
i mean i agree yes so
this is very scary very scary uh
times we're living in it's very alarming
yeah
and they're doing it with toys too and i
i think i sent you
yeah the voice okay so now with this
netflix film so now you have these young
girls
you have this muslim girl who's growing
up and now you have
these um the other young girls they're
trying to get them to do the whole
twerking stuff and all it all it all
seems like it's under the
umbrella of just fun we're just having
fun freedom
what do you think about that all these
terms that are just nice they're nice
term slogans that are put out there
but then the under what's the agenda
underneath
right it seems it's uh this poisonous
yeah the agenda is is freedom at all
cost
and it's leading our kids in into
rebellion against their parents
um rebellion and revolt against you know
probably their traditional if they're in
any type of
religious or cultural um family setting
it's to break out and to be your own
person and to have fun
no matter what pleasure is everything
and sexual pleasure
especially there is
a big outrage also in we've had a lot of
have you seen a lot of christian groups
or
jewish or that have that have spoken out
against this
this film from netflix i know there was
a petition
yes there was a
change.org um that i know i think they
got up to 170 000
um and and i know that
um netflix did send out a twitter
message apologizing
but they didn't remove it from netflix
they just changed the um
poster uh because the one that you
showed
was the changed version the first one
was the girls
in their um scanty costumes
in provocative oh wait wait so the one
that
we just showed was a toned down one
there was one worse than that
yes yeah that's the toned down one they
portrayed these um
11 year old girls as las vegas showgirls
like basically like
s